in a year that demanded heroes
they weren't in short supply and those
whose efforts have helped us all fight
back against the virus
are now being honored we started trials
professor andrew pollard oversaw the
development of the oxford vaccine which
was achieved in just eight months
he's been knighted for services to
public health but says credit should go
to a lot more than just him and his team
and perhaps even more important to the
people who took part in the clinical
trials
and who actually made this possible and
have brought
this vaccine that's now being delivered
all around the world
so they're they're heroes as well they
are all heroes they are they're all part
of this
army that's been fighting against
coronavirus with us
leading that army was kate bingham chair
of the vaccine task force
she's been made a dame as has professor
sarah gilbert
another of the life-saving vaccine
pioneers
their colleague divya chattamanic led
the clinical trials for the jabs
convincing manufacturers to conduct them
in britain she's been made an obe
the culmination of something she says
began with what her father said when she
left home in india
to study in the uk he said do good
be good and do something amazing so that
you do get to meet the queen
my dad did pass away in december so for
me this is an
ultimate culmination the honours is an
ultimate culmina
culmination of i hope i've done good i
hope i've been able to do
something um and at some point maybe
meet the queen if not in person but at
least this this comes just as close
these pans they look rather big but they
just about make all the food that we
need
but it's not just the scientists who've
made a difference anju alawalia runs a
charity feeding london's homeless
and has been awarded the british empire
medal before the pandemic they were
cooking 900 meals a week at most
but when covid hit that became 5000 as
they responded to all those in need
some of these people they didn't have
money
because they had been furloughed or they
didn't have jobs or they were
self-employed and they couldn't prove
that
they didn't know where their next meal
was coming from and
i'm a massive believer in that every
single human being on the planet
needs to have at least one hot meal a
day footballer raheem sterling is among
the non-covid related honours
given an mbe for services to racial
equality and sport
while there are knighthoods for two
prominent tory donors philanthropist
william adley
and trail finders founder michael gooly
who have been honored for services to
charity
their companies both donated half a
million pounds to the conservatives
in the run-up to the last election but
the overriding theme of those being
recognized
is the pandemic the worst of times
bringing out
the best in many iva bennett sky news